what do you think about the way uh
trudeau is handling canada
terrible like that guy's an elitist snap
somebody ought to kick his ass i
shouldn't say that i'm gonna say i'm
saying something but he's over there
lying he's calling those truckers nazis
you might have some idiot out there with
a swastika but those are hard-working
men and women who love their country
they're not nazis and he knows it
they're doing talking points that come
from political analysts and consultants
and they put that stuff out there to
mislead the public
just like russian collusion and some of
the other stuff my own experience i can
see it i know it so i don't like him at
all i think he's terrible and he's a a
guy he's the son of a former prime
minister he's never done any heavy
lifting in his life he's never said he's
a former son of a former prime minister
pierre trudeau was his father oh no no
i thought you were saying he's the son
of a former prime minister castro i
thought that's where you know trudeau i
got you true former prime minister of
canada so he grew up as an elitist and
uh
you know and living the good life never
did any real work and the idea that
truck drivers who do real work who bring
us the food that we ate and all the
other stuff that we need that he'd be
treating him that way offends me and
he's
he is a member of a political party in
canada that would be the member would be
the political party i was a member of
hearing ill in america did you see that
video with the with the the cops
trampled over that old lady the the
horse did you see that video in the
video can you play that video it's very
disturbing by the way
uh uh watch what happens here
what is happening here
what is this lady doing traveling
horses struggling
[Applause]
we went over
[Music]
they just trampled that lady
they just fully trampled that way this
is in canada this is actually trucker's
approach you know you saw this in
australia you never thought this would
happen in canada but the
the thing with
when you see these videos with cops i
can't believe
i have a hard time believing that all
these cops
fully agree with trudeau so you know
what i'm saying like i have a very hard
time believing that so imagine the job
that you have to do
but you disagree with the way the guy's
treating everybody there it's the same
as the ss in 1945 it's just they're
they're sitting back and they're quiet
you look at the video there was a from
the same
uh protest there was a video of cops
beating a woman with the butt of a rifle
they the woman got pulled over onto the
side of the cops they were they were on
top of her and they started beating her
with the butt of this rifle and it's
like they're they're they need to speak
up and say something or else they're
going to become a real problem i mean
they're going to become the ss and the
brown shirts it's because they're afraid
to speak up and speak their mind they
just do what they're told and obey the
orders
you know it's like this
everyone everybody believes in back the
blue and i don't i don't debate that
right but you can only do that so far at
some point the blue have to stand up and
realize that they're more than just
um somebody who's given an order they
have to speak up and stand up and say no
this isn't what we signed up for this
isn't what we took our oath for this
isn't this isn't who we are yeah i mean
what are they going to do they're now
towing trucks now they're impounding
them
and they're hurting that's still going
to backfire on them because you need
those guys to keep driving these trucks
the truck drivers don't have the most
luxurious
lifestyle you know they're they're not
around the most they're away from their
kids they don't see their wives and kids
for god knows weeks at a time days at a
time
you need those guys to work those are
not people that you want to discourage
them from working everybody's affected
by it
what's that you're putting up up there
we hear your concern for people on the
ground after the horses despair the
crowd anyone who fell got up and walked
away we are unaware of any injuries a
bicycle was thrown
at the horse
further down the line and caused the
horse to trip the horse was uninjured
what are we supposed to do with that
this this is the
statement from ottawa police about
trampling the woman
that's how they responded to it so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you